how's it going my name is Pippa let's
talk about money for a little bit
yesterday it was all over Facebook how
much money I made in 2014 there were
some articles that trended and it just
it was everywhere like it was not just
on Facebook money is the topic that I
purposely try to avoid for the five
years that I've been making videos
because I just I just feel like it's not
important to anyone and I just want to
make entertaining videos don't get me
wrong though I don't hate money I'm not
gonna pretend like it doesn't matter to
me because it matters to everyone but
when I started doing YouTube I was in
college I was in a student loan I
couldn't even afford a proper computer
that I could record gameplay on so I was
lucky I managed to sell some artwork
that I made online and that's how I was
able to get started some of you know
this story but shortly after I quit
college and so I had to get a job and I
took whatever job I could get which was
to work in a hotdog stand and a lot of
people like to take this story as
something negative we were like oh he
did that or I can't believe he used to
sell hotdogs now look at him making big
bucks it wasn't like that at all for me
I was the happiest I was at that time
because I was finally for the first time
in many many years doing what I wanted
to do and the fact that I could make
videos was so much more important to me
that I had to spend a few hours a day
doing a job that wasn't that prestigious
I didn't know you could be big yet and
well I know people who were big at other
type of videos but there was no one big
at gaming and I didn't know you could
make money out of it so it was never
like a career that I just quit college
to pursue it's just something I just
love to do and here we are five years
later and it's it's exploded and what
people I guess don't really think about
until it's in their face is that I have
nine billion views and that translates
to something there's ads in my videos I
make money out of those so whenever it
comes out how much I made a certain year
people just get so shocked
and a lot of people also which I saw
were very very angry they thought it was
unfair they thought I just said on my
ass all day and I just yell at the
screen over here we're just true but
there's so much more to it than that and
I understand that people just haters
gonna hate right but I don't know I I'd
really think that money doesn't make you
happy I am just as happy as I am now as
I was five years ago I'm I'm very happy
that I don't have to worry about paying
rent because that was a huge issue when
my state came over to Sweden we could
barely afford it so I might be about
that but other than that it doesn't
change much justice and to see so many
people of being upset about this whole
thing it's just it's a sad I think it's
it's it's such a waste I selected some
of my few favorite comments just to read
for fun let's if only I could get paid
that much for being a complete [ __ ] in
front of a webcam and generate a few
million views all right I have a very
nice camcorder thank you very much I
think that's what's cool about YouTube
that anyone could technically do it
right surely if I didn't exist
there'd be someone to fill my place I do
work a tremendous amount like I asked my
girlfriend and I think Alex if you do it
too you could do it I believe in you I
find it funny how someone who yells and
plays video games make this much money
when there are people out there who risk
their lives fighting for this country
and they get paid hardly anything with
this country I'm gonna assume you mean
America I mean yeah you're right war is
such a better cause that needs more of
our money and attention that it's really
worked out well throughout history so
you make a really good point there oh
here's one that I see a lot which is
mmm-hmm should be getting paid this much
instead at least mm-hmm is actually
funny it really doesn't matter what you
think life is not
there it's just how it is if you think
someone else is funnier go refresh their
videos over and over cuz that's how we
get paid hey everyone I can scream at
nothing I mean I scream in games it'd be
kind of awesome if I scream at nothing
though mega lame sex jokes not gonna
argue with that and a rape joke even if
I have to apologize for it dress up in
female underwear and do the Harlem shake
give me millions of dollars if you look
as good as I do in a bikini then you
could probably pull it off but I I
sincerely doubt that you do so I'm sorry
well people have to understand that
PewDiePie was located in one of the
European countries which gained their
views then moved to Italy so he gets all
of their views I got all of the views
from Italy
holy [ __ ] plus he has an
english-speaking channel which gains him
views for every english-speaking country
I never been featured on the Italian
front page of YouTube have you seen the
Italian front page of YouTube it's
literally only football honestly I don't
know why I became big either
conclusion it seems like the whole world
cares more about how much money I make
then I do myself and we did raise a
million dollars to charity and very few
articles picked up on that but here it
is everywhere how much money I make I
don't think there's any good reason why
anyone should care and now on top of
that I guess there's no good reason why
I should care either so we're just gonna
end it there I do want to finish off by
just saying thank you so much to all of
you who watch my videos enjoy them and
support what I do it really does mean a
lot and I'm just happy doing this I
would be doing it even if I was still
not as big as I am or whatever I'm sorry
I had to raise the video on this but I
just felt like it needed to be said all
right back